every musician dreams of writing and
performing a song that resonates with
the people who hear it when that song
becomes part of a movie it's forever
bonded with the spirit and the message
of the film the songs nominated this
year are as powerful as the films in
which they appeared three of them have
been performed for us tonight
here are the nominees for Best Original
Song mentoring from racing extinction
music by Jay Ralph lyric by anole simple
song number three from youth music and
lyric by David lang earned it from Fifty
Shades of Grey music and lyric by the
weekend
Ahmad [ __ ] Jason Quinn evil and
Stefan Macchio till it happens to you
from the hunting ground music and lyric
by Diane Warren and Lady gaga
writings on the wall from Specter
by Jimmy napes and Sam Smith and the
Oscar goes to Jimmy napes and Sam Smith
for writings on the wall
for Jimmy napes
I actually can't breathe right now
oh my gosh thank you to this man here
Jimmy napes and to all the nominees
you're incredible gaga you're incredible
I read an article a few months ago by
Sir Ian McKellen and he said that no
openly gay man had ever won an Oscar and
and if this is the case even if it isn't
the case I want to dedicate this to the
LGBT community all around the world
I stand here I stand here tonight as a
proud gay man and I hope we can all
stand together as equals one day thank
you so much
hmm